the human body is made up of different
tissues each with a specialist function
let's zoom into the liver
tissues are made up of cells specialized
to perform different functions let's
look inside this liver cell
within each cell are specialized
structures and compartments called
organelles the genome is found within an
organelle called the nucleus
the genome is packaged into structures
called chromosomes
there are 23 pairs of chromosomes
including two chromosomes that determine
your sex men have one X chromosome and
one Y chromosome women have two X
chromosomes
each chromosome is a length of DNA cord
up tightly to create structures called
chromatin loops
when we look closer at these loops we
can see the DNA is wrapped around
proteins known as histones to form
structures called nucleosomes
DNA itself is a double helix like a
twisted ladder it is made up of four
letters or bases called adenine cytosine
guanine and thymine a C G and T
a always pairs with T and C always pairs
with G
the order or sequence of these letters
of DNA carry the instructions for how a
cell behaves and functions specific
sections of the DNA called genes Co the
instructions for producing molecules the
human genome contains about 23,000 genes
you can think of the genome as an
encyclopedia and the chromosomes as the
books that make up the set if you were
to print out all three billion letters
of the human genome you would make 120
books